[Musique]
bonjour pierre marie joseph bonjour
président d'honneur de la mp
l'association martiniquaise pour la
promotion du ski vous étiez le président
de 7 à un pays au moment de la grève
d'il ya dix ans ce matin quand vous
entendez là certes ical serez
l'intersyndicale se réunir et dire
qu'elle réfléchit à l'idée de mener des
actions car les accords de 2009 n'ont
pas été respectées ça vous fait quoi
vous etc est un petit peu à la limite
mais enfin ceci étant dit il est certain
que les le contexte est pas tout à fait
le même nous savons que c'est une
grecque a démarré avec la guyane puis la
guadeloupe et il ya eu un effet
d'entraînement surtout n'oublions pas
qu'il ya eu un creux d'un grand malaise
à ce moment là dans les fonctions
publiques et nous avons eu donc un
contexte il ya eu donc le coût de la vie
a eu le carburant qui a augmenté à ce
moment là de façon importante les
produits alimentaires dont aussi et nous
avions et nous avons eu aussi des
demandes donc sur des salaires
supplémentaires et tous à changer tout
ça n'a pas n'a pas totalement changé
puisque nous avons un certain nombre de
mots qui persiste il ya des choses qui
ont évolué bien sûr donc car un
mouvement aussi important inédit dans
l'histoire de la martinique en ce qui me
concerne depuis que je suis peut-être né
c'est un mouvement inédit et c'est vrai
que beaucoup
certaines choses ont changé d'autres peu
moins mais qui nécessite des réformes
beaucoup plus profonde entre
l'intersyndicale parle de recréer les
conditions d'une grande mobilisation
populaire comme il y a dix ans selon
vous rien ne laisse présager de nouveaux
départs de soulèvements de masse alors
pour vous je n'ai pas dis ça je dis si
vous savez une population
quand on regarde les indicateurs
socio économique que nous avons
actuellement c'est quand même par beau
fixe nous avons nous sommes quand même
nous pouvons évoluer de crise en crise
mais enfin aujourd'hui les indicateurs
le taux chômage reste est élevé le le
coût de la vie est élevé le pouvoir
d'achat des gens et toute façon il est
certain que nous sommes en permanence à
parle de pouvoir d'achat mais le pouvoir
d'achat est important parce qu'il lui la
consommation qui tirent aussi la
production qui bat thierry qui
m'attirait l'économie vers le haut or
aujourd'hui il est certain qu'il ya un
problème
donc au niveau de la nive au delà de la
consommation car tu dois encore une fois
la grande distribution celle qui est
celle qui permet d'avoir accès aux
aliments qui nous permette de vivre à
l'époque on se souvient et jean claude
williams l'universitaire l'a rappelé
hier il y avait certes le prix de
l'essence la vie chère au départ une
tendance identitaire et puis la grande
distribution la profitation le patronat
comment vous étiez à l'époque lorsque
vous avez vu tout seul à émerger
si vous voulez je crois qu'il faut
entrer dans le dans le fond des choses
car il faut trouver les boucs émissaires
c'est vrai que on peut peut-être ci a
tellement améliorer des choses il ya
peut-être certains c'est une activité où
certains acteurs qui en profitent mais
d'une façon générale il faut il faut
voir la problématique de façon entière
nous avons eu une île nous sommes donc
sûrs sur une hymne sur sur l'insularité
nous sommes dans un département français
qu'on le veuille ou non avec toutes les
charges tous les coups français et nous
avons aucun moyen de pouvoir
l'insularité provoqué et insulté tous
les souks ou que nous avons donc
entraîne
son épouse il a été indiqué souvent une
augmentation des primes se souvient
pierre marie josèphe qu'il y avait la
dénonciation de manque de transparence
on ne comprenait pas le mécanisme de
fabrication des prix est ce
qu'aujourd'hui tout est clean tout et
tout est transparent des choses ont
beaucoup évolué et je crois que les gens
se sont approprié la formation du prix
du prix de revient et du prix de vente
des produits
nous savons aujourd'hui que je pense
qu'il ya une prise de conscience qui est
fait sur le modèle économique dans
lequel nous fournit à tel point que par
exemple les pièces automobiles dans les
commandes sur internet parce que c'est
juste plus supportable prix les prix
affichés par exemple je n'ai pas
seulement martinique on commande sur
internet le e-commerce
il est il est partout dans le monde
aujourd'hui mais tout le monde va
chercher effectivement acheter moins
cher mais il va de soi que acheter moins
cher commander tout tout à l'extérieur
il y à il ya certainement un modèle qui
est à revoir
et alors ça ça sans s'impliquer
comportement ça implique les
comportements des consommateurs mais
aussi les acteurs économiques donc et
des fournisseurs
il ya un dialogue social oui oui je
crois que dialogue social a beaucoup
évolué mais ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
depuis 2000 2000-2009 ainsi bien avant
vous savez bien que nous avons eu une
action sur le dialogue social en 2000 et
qui a fait qu'avec la rade que nous
avons lancé avec le directeur du travail
fort narrow tout une toute une des
sessions un donc cinq sessions qui ont
qui ont d'ailleurs porté leurs fruits
parce que pendant les sept années qui
ont suivi nous avons eu vraiment une
relative paix sociale avec peu de
journées de travail perdues 1 2 quand
vous dites que les choses doivent
évoluer
quel levier aimeriez vous actionnez pour
que à vaincre tout le monde se rende
compte que ça change
en tout cas qu'un processus est vraiment
lancée aujourd'hui vous avez deux
éléments importants
vous avez le chômage et la vie chère est
dépendant de l'autre donc vous avez
aujourd'hui une une économie donc qui
avec d'autres ouvertures à peine 2 enfin
depuis plutôt de 80% donc ce qui est
assez
c'est assez inquiétant vous avez vous
avez secteurs d'activité comme comme le
tertiaire qui 85% le public qui
représente 38% les services 33 % le
commerce 13% de l'activité
la bt et 8 pour sal l'industrie 7% le le
primaire 3% l'agriculture la pêche et
que c'était donc nous voyons bien que
j'avais une économie dont qui est
tournée vers le service essentiellement
donc et qui est lié et effectivement à
notre organisation et au et au modèle
que nous avons choisi d'ailleurs un nom
il faut il faut absolument que nous
soyons ambitieux et que nous arrivions à
baisser nos prix parce que
l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat
il n'est pas seulement en augmentant en
augmentant les salaires
il peut être aussi en diminuant les prix
vraiment comment pouvons-nous diminuer
les prix mais justement se pose la
question
avant-hier lundi nous recevions louis
maugée de la cgtm qui disait que vin
d'honneur après 2009 ya quand même de
grands groupes qui ont profité qui n'ont
pas eu à se plaindre finalement de cette
grève parce qu'elle se retrouve parmi
les plus grosses fortunes de france
alors failli ayotte une des prouesses
fabre est parfaite lioen qui pèsent à
elles cinq et près d'un milliard du
roller chiffre d'affaires qui augmentent
leurs capacités leurs placements
financiers qui qui qui augmente ça veut
dire finalement que ce sont des patrons
qui disent tout le temps qui a crise
qu'il ya crise mais pourtant les
affaires fonctionnent non mais je crois
qu'il fait il fait beaucoup plus
réalisés les années à venir
non c'est pas les dom c'est monsieur
mauger qui le dit aussi c'est
l'interprétation de louis maugée de la
cgtm chiffres donnés par l'iedom de de
monsieur roger mais ceci étant dit il
faut quand même regarder aussi le tissu
économique de la martinique
je reste persuadé que les que les grands
groupes de distribution alimentaire
certainement qu'ils peuvent peut-être
mieux au niveau des prix mais leur marge
donc le résultat final n'est pas plus
élevé que les résultats des groupes donc
de discussion alimentaire de métropole
et peut-être et sont certainement à mon
avis inférieur au regard justement du
petit marché sur lequel nous sommes est
la densité de dire je crois qu'on est
aussi sous du réalisme
il faut il faut quand même que nous
passions patients
vers une réflexion macroéconomique est à
mon sens est il faut l'appeler projets
économiques et il faudrait si vous
voulez des mutations économiques parce
qu'elles sont elles sont nécessaires
avec beaucoup d'ambition et ça c'est nos
élus se sont aussi sujets décrit comme
un candidat grossi depuis 2009
ah mais c'est pas c'est pas depuis 2009
il a grossi ouais je crois que nous
avons suivi une évolution tout à fait
normal j'étais lake est justement la
recette par exemple pour quelqu'un comme
vous pierre marie josèphe
on se souvient de que 2009 il ya eu
beaucoup d'emplois qui ont été perdus il
ya eu des entreprises qui ont fermé mais
vous vous avez pu continuer dans ce
contexte de crise on le rappelle de
difficultés économiques
comment quelle est la recette pour vous
selon vous le travail la rigueur la
discipline une gestion efficace une
gestion collective avec avec avec nos
salariés nous avons oeuvré nous devrons
beaucoup dans dans les services
messi mais il faut il faut quand même
rappeler pour revenir à la crise de 2009
que la martinique a perdu plus de 4000
emplois entre 2009 et 2013 et jusqu'à
présent nous voyons bien que nous sommes
encore dans un dans une très difficile d
investissement de 2,2 de choix de choix
d'investissement par les opérateurs qui
ne sont pas toujours ce matin je peux
être efficient pour le développement de
la martinique
parce que nous avons besoin manifeste de
création d'emplois et ça et cela je vous
dis c'est ce qui m'inquiète le plus
c'est cette jeunesse donc qui est
aujourd'hui qui n'est pas employé nous
voyons que nous avons quasiment 60% de
nos jeunes qui sont au chômage
nous avons nous avons un nombre de
jeunes qui ont une formation entre
laisser happer le bac
donc il faut faire un gros travail sur
la formation professionnelle et la ja ja
il ya un champ d'investigation hyper
important dans lequel d'ailleurs mon
groupe dont s'est inscrit résolument car
il faut que la martinique puis se
puissent bénéficier de 2 2 d'un certain
nombre de jeunes beaucoup plus fort mais
qui ne sont actuellement fermés joseph
au lendemain de la grève de deux
correspondent aux besoins surtout au
lendemain de la grève de 2009
le patron à la limite avait presque
honte d'être patron est aujourd'hui six
semaines
c'est ce même schéma et ce qu'est ce que
l'on me gare sur sur celui qui crée de
la richesse qu'ils feraient une
entreprise qui crée de l'emploi est ce
que ça a changé
moi je pense je pense que en 2009 n'est
pas il n'ya pas nous s'est montré des
traces et des patrons a montré du doigt
c'est normal mais c'était tout à fait
normal façon quand il ya une relation
duale elle est entre le patronat et les
salariés ben quoi de quoi qu'il en soit
il faut assumer nous avons assumé donc
largement nos responsabilités nous
créions l'emploi nous créons la richesse
mais avec nos salariés
jamais un patron ne réussisse avait tout
seul il a réussi avec des équipes
donc il faut savoir fédérer autour de
vous des équipes et travailler
travailler ensemble ce que nous avons
essayé de faire de notre groupe que
beaucoup de sociétés martiniquaise donc
réalise aujourd'hui en 15 secondes
le salarié d'aujourd'hui il a changé par
rapport à 2009 certainement parce que
l'épée les patrons comme vous dites
aussi ont aussi changé tout le monde va
changer nous sommes dans un monde en
pleine évolution
nous avons donc
à nos portes l'intelligence artificielle
nous avons ici est un nombre de choses
qui se mettre en place il faut que nous
nous puissions évoluer nous salariés
évoluent nos entreprises évoluent et
nous évoluons nous aussi car marie
josèphe président d'honneur de la mp
merci d'avoir été ce matin avec nous
dans son crédit bonne journée
[Musique]